tu t'es laver les mains avec du savon
tu les a bien séché devenu malgré lui
c'est moi sinon est ce qu il est prévu
qu'on en parle un jour quoique du sujet
tabou évidemment quel sujet tabou le
nouveau travail de maman il est temps
grand temps de réparer nos erreurs
aidez nous à faire sortir de l'ombre
tous les supers nous devons changer
l'opinion des gens sur les super-héros
et pour cela élastique earl est notre
meilleur atout meilleur que moi
[Musique]
alors marc cherry je m'occupe des
enfants pas de problème c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut faire quoi le prof dit
qu'on peut utiliser cette méthode je
connais pas cette méthode est pourquoi
ils changent les maths les box et les
maths les marchés démarraient bien super
c soit la petite de deux danses et jack
jack est très en forme c'est quoi ça ok
d'accord ça c'est plus bas c'est
complètement fou non pour aider ma
famille et je dois la quitte t il pour
sa veniez la loi pour la transgresser
pour nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent
avoir le choix
[Musique]
combustion imminent qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire y'a le feu
aubin
l'une au teaser en terro ce programme
afin de vous délivrer un message en film
en costumes ça va chauffer j'arrive tu
me dépêcher
[Musique]